[Musique]
mais c'est moi y'a des fois j'ai
carrément envie d'être amie avec
moi-même quoi parce que je fais des
cadeaux de noël à chaque femme plus de
programmes à la fois cette année ton
cadeau il vraiment trop bien trop hâte
que tu le vois tu quoi je peux dire à ta
juste à attendre demande et wazemmes a
fait un truc cool j'espère parce que moi
je me suis sur place des stades est un
hymne au rock parce que ce matin je me
suis réveillé je pensais qu'on était le
4 décembre du roi c'est mon rôle je me
suis complètement laissé porter par le
temps
était
[Musique]
docker tu te que welcome to pas ton
budget à islande fait d'avoir la petite
idée là qu'il a bien voilà on voulait
vous embrasser on va vous faire un petit
live l'a rapidement là on sait que vous
l'aimez bien les live by you again
amy
alors les enfants est ce que c'est bien
le ski c'est à dire et vous avez vu papa
comment il skie bien non
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas tombé c'est pas vrai oui
mais c'est bon bon c'est bon c'est bon
oui c'est ça
et bisous je vous aime
oui on y allait
ah ouais enfin